this is fantastic this is just yesterday
Democrat congresswoman named Tricia
cotham from North Carolina
she's no longer a Democrat she's moving
over to the Gob
modern day Democratic party has become
unrecognizable to me
and to so many others throughout this
state and this country
the party wants to villainize anyone who
has free thought
free judgment has Solutions who wants to
get to work to better our state not just
sit in a meeting and have a workshop
after a workshop but really work with
individuals to get things done because
that's what real public servants do
if you don't do exactly what the
Democrats want you to do they will try
to bully you they will try to cast you
aside I got to tell you guys uh watching
that is so affirming for me personally
because what she says there about free
thought and what they will do for you to
you and and when you step away and all
that stuff literally you've all seen it
I'm sure my why I left the left video I
did on Prager you seven years ago that's
what I was saying and now that is you
know that time release pill truth is
Time released people more and more
people are realizing it what's
interesting about this also Phoenix just
told me that her switching from Democrat
to GOP now gives the Republicans a super
majority in North Carolina so watch
watch what happens now in North Carolina
I bet you it will become more stable it
will become safer they will protect kids
they will not allow for this woke
nonsense and everything else so this is
this is a really really nice moment
[Music]
all
right
[Music]